did you ever meet Steve Jobs no I never
met Steve Jobs I spoke to him on the
phone three times he called me once just
to tell me that he likes something that
I had written he called me the second
time to invite me up to tour Pixar he
wanted me to write a Pixar film and I
said I love Pixar movies but I I don't
think I can make an inanimate object
talk and he said as soon as you make a
talk it won't be an animate and I
thought I'm not getting into an argument
with Steve Jobs yeah yeah and then the
third time was to just to ask for some
help on the Stanford commencement
address that he asked you for her that's
a very famous iconic it Beach it is and
it's a great speech I have nothing to do
with its greatness I I fixed some typos
that he had write did you get a sense of
who he was I mean I will say this Steve
Wozniak has said that this film really
gets Steve Jobs right yeah that's a
great thing to hear from woz that I got
a sense from who he was by talking to
dozens and dozens of people who knew him
very well and loved him very much from
woz to his eldest daughter Lisa who
hasn't didn't talk before Lisa Lisa
listen this movie is based on the
biography the authorized biography by
Walter Isaacson fantastic book it is a
fantastic book but Lisa was unwilling to
speak to Walter because her father was
alive at the time and she was worried
about alienating her father her mother
her stepmother perhaps all three Lisa is
a wonderful woman now you guys have the
same alma mater she's she's a terrific
essayist and and she was willing to talk
to me and that was really my way into
the movie and so this gave you an
incredible insight into him and what's
interesting about this movie I'll make
this point now it is not your tip it's
not a biopic in science that it doesn't
start in the 1950s and then we watch him
grow it's not a cradle to grave right
Rock sure where you get the guy's
greatest hits along the way and then he
coughs and goes to the doctor and dies
right the entire movie is
I don't shy I don't mean to be glib
about a man's butt but that that is the
structure of a biopic right this isn't
one the entire movie is three scenes
that each take place in real time real
time of course is when thirty minutes
for you and the audience is the same as
30 minutes for yes a character on the
screen and they each take place
backstage in the moments before one of
his product launches yes there's three
different product launches they all have
three very different kinds of outcomes
and you see him backstage getting ready
each time and wrestling with just not
just the business side but the emotional
what he's going out of personal points
of friction and and that's hopefully how
we got to know him better it's it's not
really for me to say is the writer but I
think it's a it's a very entertaining
ride